bonjour monsieur Martel
on a entendu ça le deux pompiers
disparus en faisant leur métier dont un
jeune de 23 ans sa déchire l'âme
d'entendre ça tout à fait triste réalité
il faut comprendre que les pompiers on
en avait déjà parlé par le passé qu'ils
ont beaucoup de tâches à accomplir donc
ces gens-là ont été dépêchés pour
participer aux inondations mais il faut
comprendre que les inondations c'est
c'est je vous dirais une super
spécialité donc
on retrouve de l'eau vive mais on
retrouve de l'eau qui est sorti de son
lit donc qui est encore plus
problématique et c'est de l'eau qui est
qu'on pourrait qualifier qui est comme
déchaîné donc c'est très très compliqué
pour les pompiers mais malheureusement
très très triste ce qui se passe
présentement en effet on le sait les on
le dit de plus en plus souvent les
pompiers ne combattent pas seulement des
incendies ils Inter est en pleine
situation d'urgence notamment parce
qu'ils sont premiers répondant je
présume qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement
je vous dirais que une double
connotation premier répondant
habituellement on associe à
aide médicale donc c'est habituellement
c'est à ça qu'on fait référence mais on
parle aussi de premier répondant
c'est-à-dire des intervenants de
première ligne c'est à dire que ouais
lorsqu'il se passe quelque chose dans
une municipalité
habituellement on appelle toujours les
pompiers donc ils sont toujours
disponibles donc c'est eux qu'on appelle
malheureusement des fois toujours en
premier et la particularité des services
incendie dans des petites municipalités
évidemment c'est qu'ils sont faits de
pompiers à temps partiel on les appelait
des pompiers volontaires mais ce sont
véritablement des pompiers à temps
partiel est-ce qu'ils ont la même
formation ils ont certainement pas la
même expérience
dans les deux cas je vous dirais au
niveau de la formation non c'est tout à
fait différent il y a un programme pour
les grandes municipalités exemple comme
MONT où est-ce que les gens ont affaire
des études beaucoup plus longues et
lorsqu'on parle de pompiers à temps
partiel c'est la formation qui est donné
oui comme les week-ends
il y a pas de mobilier urbain il y a pas
de clôture il y a pas de bande parc il y
a pas de voiture donc c'est tous ces
risques là qui sont supplémentaires et
que les gens qui sont emportés pour être
là en contact avec ses risques là qui
sont supplémentaires qui sont très très
dangereux et on perd un peu nos repères
bien sûr quand l'eau n'est plus là où
elle est censé être tout à fait et il y
a quelque chose aussi qui s'installe
c'est que on a on ne prend pas autant
parfois au sérieux où la dangerosité de
l'inondation de l'eau qui est sorti son
lit par rapport à un cours d'eau initial
donc il faut faire très très attention à
ça je vais vous poser une question
vraiment d'amateur là mais quand on des
pompiers interviennent dans des
situations comme celle-là des crues
absolument soudaine et terrible moi je
les imagine équipé comme quand ils vont
au feu c'est à dire avec un équipement
super lourd est-ce que par ailleurs ils
ont un équipement disons adapté
cette situation là d'intervention en
temps d'inondation je vous dirais que
majoritairement non la quasi-totalité la
plupart des services vont souvent
utiliser le matériel qu'ils ont pour le
sauvetage nautique ou la sauvetage sur
glace mais c'est pas de l'équipement qui
est approprié très souvent pour des
inondations bon parmi les tâches que les
pompiers accomplissent dans des
situations d'urgence comme celle-là
est-ce que se trouve aussi la tâche
d'aller dans les maisons vers les gens
pour les convaincre de quitter ou pour
les évacuer ce que ça fait aussi partie
de leur tâche tout à fait mais là je
vous dirais aussi que c'est en rapport
aussi avec la priorité de des gestes à
accomplir où ils vont le faire mais
s'ils ont pas le personnel
supplémentaire ça va être donné à
quelqu'un d'autre cette tâche là puis
les pompiers vont se consacrer vraiment
là à sauver des gens si on veut à
l'intervention d'urgence et on les
comprend ils sont formés pour ça et ils
ont cette espèce
si on peut dire je pense que c'est un
peu humain là mais forcément quand on
est pompier on doit encore plus vouloir
sauver des gens tout à fait et puis si
on prend aussi les gens qui font ça
aussi à temps partiels qu'ils ont un
autre métier c'est très très honorable
de donner de son temps aussi pour pour
sauver des gens ou pour participer là à
régler des situations urgences en effet
c'est important c'est risqué on le
constate dans un Martel merci beaucoup
d'être patient studio au plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI